tell me his name again
your Herald summons you another world
awaits let it be done quickly hey
everybody it's Charlie so I got a
billion requests yesterday to do a video
about Silver Surfer in infinity war I
was a little confused I was like wait a
minute why does everybody think that
Silver Surfer is going to be an infinity
war until I did a little digging if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
gonna be crazy infinity war happening
and there's an Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway happening that I'll explain at
the end of the video but all this Silver
Surfer nonsense stems from a Metacritic
page that has this massive cast list so
if you haven't seen any of those recent
preview videos that I've posted they
talked about how there's 60 plus
characters named characters that appear
just in infinity war that doesn't
include any extra people that'll pop up
during Avengers 4 Captain Marvel is in
it
Black Widow Scarlet Witch
we have Wakanda is coming in and there's
a whole group of characters that are
coming from the wakandan universe so
massive cast list you start scrolling
down the page here you're like okay you
know Black Panther rocket racoon you
start scrolling down Pepper Potts makes
sense of course Pepper Potts to be in
the film Hawkeye's wife sure sounds
pretty reasonable you slowly go down
past all these Black Panther Guardians
characters and all of a sudden you see
down here below Maria Hill Silver Surfer
and you're like it wait a minute Silver
Surfer that seems kind of crazy the
whole thing about this is like you
actually go to that actors IMDB page
there's no infinity war on there so yes
of course there's gonna be a lot of
surprises during infinity war people we
never heard about big twist there's
always things that they can add at the
last minute but the thing about Silver
Surfer is that he's a core Fox character
meaning that he would have no way of
showing up during infinity war unless
this Fox Disney deal was completely done
in right now as of the release of
infinity war like when it actually hits
theaters they'll still be in the lawyer
stage of that dealing with how they're
going to break all the different little
pieces up if things go bad so status
update on that Fox Disney deal you
probably heard about the billion movies
that Fox is developing like why are they
making
those movies if they're gonna be bought
by Disney won't Kevin Feige want to make
the movies that he wants to make when he
gets access to those characters the
thing about that like the reason why the
Fox still has all those crazy movies on
their schedule is is because they want
to pump up their value going into this
merger so that they can get more money
out of the deal it's the same thing with
Sony developing its spider-verse like
the silver and black movie like you know
that sounds kind of weird I can
understand them wanting to do a venom
movie but there's like a billion
different spider-man movies that don't
directly involve the spider-man
character it a lot of that goes into the
idea that they want to show potential
buyers that might buy sony's movie
studio that they have a lot of value so
if they put a lot of movies on their
schedule they say look at all these
crazy movies we're developing see how
much money we're gonna make on this then
they're more likely to attract a
corporate suitor so the thing with Fox
is that it just needs to be business as
usual until somebody actually tells
Kevin Feige oh yeah you know we bought
them the government approved the buyout
deal so you can use these characters
however you want that takes years so
even if Kevin Feige did get access to
these Fox characters people like James
Gunn that have already turned in their
draft for guardians three have said that
they're not going to be changing any of
their movie plans even if everything
goes according to plan with the Disney
Fox deal meaning that all the stuff that
you see happen during Avengers infinity
war in Avengers 4 was predetermined a
long time ago yes of course Galactus
would be the perfect follow-up villain
in the cosmic universe to Thanos so like
it took three phases to get to Thanos
wouldn't it be awesome if the next big
arc led to a confrontation with Galactus
for us Kevin Feige usually has a billion
different ideas for movies based on
deals that either work out or don't work
out when Spiderman came along for Civil
War there was the potential that the
deal could fall through they were gonna
make black panther a much bigger
character during that scenario so he
just had multiple different options in
case the really cool thing didn't work
out James Gunn architect of the cosmic
universe probably has a lot of ideas for
how to use some of those Fox characters
but because people have been asking him
ever since they announced this Fox
Disney thing will you change your plans
if everything works out and he's like no
guardians three is already predetermined
he's turned into draft of the script
he's not gonna change that even if they
do get access to those Fox characters
before they start shooting the movie
because usually that's the time to
change things like oh hey by the way you
can use Silver Surfer now feel free to
put them in your movie before you start
to shoot it the top of everyone's wish
list right now for the end of Avengers 4
is that there's some sort of Galactus
Silver Surfer tag
it is known by many names my people
called it Galactus the Devourer of
worlds usually the end of story arcs
like the end of Avengers 4 are used to
tee up the big concepts that are coming
next so like okay we dealt with Thanos
he's gone the threat of the Infinity
Gauntlet has abated for now but there's
more cosmic storm clouds on the horizon
so obviously we still have Dormammu I'm
interested to see how they invoke him
during these next two Avengers films I
don't think he's gonna be a really huge
character but they're already a couple
big things that they're teeing up that
are Silver Surfer related in the next
couple of Marvel movies so Captain
Marvel is actually a point of crossover
if you guys didn't know the kree-skrull
war is something they're gonna address
during that movie it'll be Marvel's
movie version of that so it probably
won't be exactly like the comics but
silver surfers homeworld was embroiled
in the kree-skrull war of the characters
that Marvel currently controls the first
big crossover that he had was with the
Thor character during his own solo title
now that didn't last very long but
probably the biggest joke right now in
the last couple of movies has been Thor
Point Break so why not make a Marvel
Point Break with Silver Surfer and Thor
crossing over
no hard feelings Point Break you've got
a mean swing
welcome voice activation required or
access denied Thor son of Odin access
denied
god of thunder access denied strongest
avenger access denied
strongest avenger access denied
damn you stock Point Break welcome but
when you're thinking about Fox Galactus
stuff just think about him the same way
that the Marvel movies used Thanos
through phase one and Phase two just
like very light touch very brief even in
the comics Galactus was sort of a
background character it was like Darth
Vader in the Emperor like you send in
the Lackey first to let people know that
their doom is coming the funny thing
that Jack Kirby actually said about
creating Silver Surfer is is that they
wanted to do Galactus they wanted this
ancient predator to come and fight the
Fantastic Four so they needed a reason
for Reed Richards to find out that his
doom was coming and leave the readers in
suspense to the end of the comic when
Galactus would actually show up Kirby
said that he had gotten sick of drawing
spaceships so he wanted to do something
different so he tried out the Silver
Surfer so both he and Stan Lee have
credit for the creation of the character
but a lot of it sounds like it came from
Jack Kirby just wanting to do something
a little bit different later writers
sort of turned the character into this
messianic figure but really Adam warlock
is the space Jesus of the Marvel
Universe but we're not gonna meet him
till guardians three so early
speculation what Marvel will probably do
is they'll introduce the idea of the
Fantastic Four
before they introduced the idea of
Silver Surfer so if there's any chance
for them showing up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe just look for Reed
Richards first and then because they do
like to do things in his traditional way
as possible if they haven't already
changed the comic book story they
introduce Silver Surfer through those
characters in a bit of a Marvel
Cinematic Universe twist so hopefully
that explains what's going on with
Silver Surfer infinity war rumors the
problem with this is that it get picked
up by a lot of news sites and they do
that question mark thing where they're
like is so first surfer an infinity war
question mark maybe maybe he is no but I
think 99% of you guys saw this and are
like hell no he's not an infinite
or so if you guys see crazy stuff like
this it's probably not true like if you
hear a Galactus shows up during infinity
war you can be like no he is not the
only thing that they would be able to do
would be include comic book references
to a lot of this stuff so yeah of course
there's gonna be a lot of comic book
Easter eggs from all across the Marvel
Universe mostly specific to Thanos and
the infinity saga but just leave all
your infinity war video requests in the
comments below there was a bunch of new
preview images that they released I'll
do a breakdown of that soon but there's
that new Superman TV show that's
debuting tonight Krypton I'll do an
episode 1 video for that there's
supposed to be some special Deadpool
stuff coming tomorrow too so I'll do a
video for that when it drops no worries
this week's Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
will stay open all week long so I'll
just remind people when I post new
Marvel but click here to go down the
Infinity war rabbit hole and click here
for all the arrow bursts Batman
references in Justice League thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]